okay for people who are joining a live
stream this is a review of functionality
for handling microcontrollers the Morton
language we've looked at some of this
before this is kind of my second look at
this so where should we start
we should start a guide I assume that
you sort of remember the big point of
this and everybody else that's gonna
have an opinion yes I think so okay good
okay
formatting the word sample project
shouldn't be in the same font that that
should be a different font I mean that
should be a different that this should
not be presented this way am I making
sense we discussed this last time so
this is exactly the way even for system
model of me okay it's not the right way
to do it it should not look like a
function name okay okay so we don't have
a precedent for this Stephenson gets an
egg not so we get one okay so Alex could
you please get Brian Vanderloo here yes
just a moment thank you okay and that's
what we're gonna make but it is crucial
that it comes on top that's fine it's
all good not a problem with that I just
wonder different style okay now why is
that a different color microcontroller
embed code that's in the microcontroller
okay but this oh these are all in that
in that so why aren't these all in that
different color
they should be am I making sense
yeah I don't know okay so that's a
mistake okay but some of these are not
some of these that some of these are
generic yes so these are there because
these are useful anything that comes but
okay these three things are all part of
and I could control a kit and they
should be in the different color and
these are all generic functions and they
should not be in the different color I
get it
okay do we have brown hair yet I'm still
working on finding him
alternatively find somebody from project
management please
okay so let's take a look at these
actual functions oops that's not good
you can just click that on the guide
beach yeah but that's only giving me
that's going to that's not going to an
editable version that's okay it's gonna
be a little bit hard to edit here if you
want to do that yeah I know but it's not
showing up I say that that's a bug of
some kind that that's not showing up
with a preview image there did you
understand what I'm saying this is
things that I'd assume uh or Brian can
answer because this is not like a normal
functions so there could be something in
the workflow build fro it's not doing
that yeah I know I know I know I know
that's the point that I'm making okay
is that really the right phraseology
Meuse either that what people call one
yeah that's an abbreviation for
microcontroller okay again there's a
fault problem there you need to get that
fixed all right
preview make sure got that yes okay I
would say by the way turn on the LED all
the native fruit I don't know what that
doesn't really matter
I'm not something okay now what on earth
is all of this okay first thing first
thing as a system the the first argument
is a system and that's the standard type
setting for yeah okay now the second
argument says the microcontroller and
this is the spec language for that okay
and why isn't that an association of
some kind I mean that naked bizarrely
nested list seems very hostile so the
way the second argument is arranged is
the first it has three cyborgs
the first one is the name of the
microcontroller the next one is the
input specification and the last one is
the output specification why don't you
make that an association so people can
see which one which one this thing here
what I'm suggesting is that this
specification and nested Association
it's not very nested it's just I know
the second argument is a list of things
so there can be multiple inputs and
outputs okay
so women this is input I thought you
said this is inputs and this is outputs
yeah right there are no inputs and one
output I don't like the fall out of this
this is crazy I'm just trying to
understand what you say right so what
I'm just a formatting thing it's this
note now I understand I understand so
what I'm suggesting here is that that
look like you know type or something and
then it's the adafruit or whatever or
whatever you want to call it
microcontroller um you know I call that
microcontroller I don't know so those
two sub lists will be Association stand
unknown in that case that's inputs is
that right yeah okay so it's a list of
inputs correct yes so all of them just
is the only decoration analog or digital
no that's why we we enumerate them in
scope there are different types this
digital analog input analog output these
are all the SPI serial okay I mean could
we instead have something which says
something like input one arrow analog
yeah yeah you can look at that in the
detail center but I'm asking the
question is the right-hand side just in
a single thing a single thing yes see if
a single thing that's only if like we
can say serial and the microcontroller
has just one serial pin you're not
understanding listen to what I'm saying
I'm saying there are inputs we've got
inputs on on you know wires - I don't
think they need to be strings I think
you should accept them as non strings
okay
to the ports of the microcontroller
right if the ports if it has numbered
ports like a Raspberry Pi has numbered
ports for GPIO right what we've done in
the in the Raspberry Pi controller is
we've just allowed integers for that and
we should do that here as well am I
making sense you know I have to look at
that so no no I'm explaining the I'm I'm
telling you what we should do okay okay
okay I really think it'd be better to
have a project manager in these meetings
so you can see here by the way Steven
that that would you have analog it's not
always just a string it can be a list of
things what can be a list of
specification the one goes to analog
that analog can also be a list no I
understand challenge specifications name
of the channel the configuration of the
channel so you know have you looked at
how the device system works because that
has had some of these issues as well
have you looked at the device I have
looked at that and is this consistent
with that or not yes because they're
they have no no no no you're not
understanding what I'm saying here oh
boy isn't it lovely that those are pink
down there
another thing could somebody needs to
report that as a bug so it's not by
design nope
no it's a bug it's been reported okay
all right
so see here okay so the way we're doing
this is for our output 17 our input okay
yeah which is not quite the same but
notice that they don't have string names
right yes but you're just seeing output
and input I understand I understand
completely
these are port numbers right and all I'm
saying is don't put them in strings okay
because sometimes we have to because
some I know that I told you put them in
strings if you have to okay don't
require them to be in strings
alright got it yeah okay I don't where
where are you saying what the names of
the other channels can be no I know it's
an OIC configuration where the
configuration possible configuration
yeah possible configurations that's what
we are in your maiden scope that's not
the right place to do it if there is a
fixed set of configurations it should be
in this details and options section but
that varies from microcontroller to
microcontroller not every microphone so
we then documenting each microcontroller
separately eventually I think that's
what we'll have to do okay I don't know
if your document I think we should have
a discovery interface so we document the
discovery interface to what there is
hundreds of them okay no no I understand
that I understand that but it like we
have four devices I think it will be
good to have separate pages for each of
these even if most of the pages
boilerplate okay you might be right
because you know this thing might get
long it might have who knows what it
might have I mean but I don't know
whether this is I mean I think it'd be
much better to put you know an Arduino
Uno page which we might already have one
all for the device framework so let me
also understand what the relationship
between the device framework and this
says did you understand my question yes
so the device framework is primarily
focused on I was gonna say data
acquisition data acquisition yes state
acquisition and that means that that can
run at a fairly slow pace yes so this is
mostly about downloading stuff to run on
the microcontroller itself right code
running on the microcontroller that's
that's all that is
we just understand the three kinds of
things that we're dealing with here okay
so we've also got system modeler and
that whole set of things somebody is
asking on the live stream about is
spiced offering these days I I would
assume that the system model stuff is
what is related to that is that yeah so
system modeler covers include system
modeler covers analog electronics in
many other domains so you can have multi
domain modeling so system modeler is the
analog of spice where you sort of
simulate the system in question okay so
just so I understand if I so in this if
I browse here what is the relationship
so we got three different things we got
the device framework we've got the
microcontroller embedding so system we
show that so we use all three frameworks
if you bring up some of the outer
documentation I can show you the v-model
of system development and then we can
sort of place where they all fit in and
by the way I assume that we also have
workflows related to the stuff in the
work flow documentation is that true no
yes
no I mean we might but it's if we used
we reused a work flow framework to give
these projects and so those projects are
like workflows I see okay okay so there
aren't generic work clothes there are
just specific projects is that correct
right you know and and and yeah that's a
great way to learn by the waiter
so this is our analog of something like
spice right right that we can then
compute from this right so typically yes
I should probably look at those projects
there hold on no yeah okay all the
workflows are broken that's where you
saw that pink pink tout I'm aware but
but these aren't workflows so am I
looking at workflows or am I looking
something different this time I'm asking
you you said there are projects which
are on the guide page right yeah yes go
back to the guide page
right those okay see but all the
workflows are broken okay so show me how
to get to this in da key tools and the
source okay that's what you need to be
able to tell me it's gonna be hard but
this is if it doesn't live in its it's
it's done as a packet I'm saying it
isn't accessible from the okay no it's
not send me that as a notebook please
one of those projects all of you can
share your screen super or you know what
I can do is I can get you to download
the better version and and and I don't
think we want something that Oh Nate
just send me the notebook please okay
either that or share your screen okay
let's see I think Brady just joined is
that correct that is correct okay so
you're standing in here for Brian
because we need to communicate some
things about documentation issues so
this is a guide page for this
microcontroller kit which relates to a
bunch of functions that are in the kit
context the microcontroller kit context
for some reason this function which is
in the microcontroller kit context isn't
showing up in this teal color here yeah
okay okay
the first point the second point is that
this page which is a link to a workflow
guide page right yeah I saw that
okay so that needs a different styling
so that will need to go through Jeremy
and get a style invented for that and my
feeling is that that should be something
which is more like and it really
shouldn't look anything like any of
these other making sense it should be
more like a button of some kind and it
absolutely shouldn't look like it's it's
the same you know same kind of link
style as this gotta make sense yep so I
just sent you that one
okay so this is that workflow so now the
dqa have no because this isn't the
backless there yeah after this they have
to okay thank you I hasn't read this so
if I notice okay all right fine
so what is this this is a link why is
there a brackets link I don't want to
understand that why isn't that just a
link from they you know for your name
here it's horrible when we do hyperlinks
that way it continues everything what do
you mean it's all the text that follow
will then be in the hyperlink style well
that's just a bug so I yeah okay Brady
that that's for you okay
okay so I mean and again the formatting
of this is less than perfect right if
that's what it's going to look like in
the final thing I think if this is if
you're saying this is the Pololu
whatever it is thing obviously there
should be a colon at the end of it to
indicate that what follows the thing is
what follows there okay can whoever is
typing in our ears please no that might
mean I'm sorry thank you okay so what's
this is that is that an additional item
which isn't pictured here yes that
doesn't note okay but that's a note not
specific to the power supply right no
okay so that needs to be reformatted so
that it's clear that that's a note that
is I mean I would do this parts list
first of all it should have less space
between these things I wouldn't bother
to have these separator lines my making
sense okay didn't know Brady are you
also being able to take notes here I'm
taking notes okay
so I mean I think that separator if you
want to have the picture of everything
together maybe I wouldn't have those
separators and then if you've got a
general note at the bottom maybe you
have to have a separator before the note
makes sense okay assembly glue together
oh my gosh you know be really nice if
this is how these Maker projects go well
I understand that you mean you don't
have a glue gun I believe that I
actually do somehow soldering irons got
easier to use over the intervening like
40 something years to be more difficult
from the past um anyway okay um
what's this why the connection so that's
now a schematic picture
yeah because some of them are a mix of
both mechanical and electrical okay
so we finished through like the
mechanical physical part up and you know
getting to the electronics what the heck
I mean this is such a weird thing for us
okay so fine and put out for sampling
period why doesn't that have units
because it's not systems models we've
never supported units there so whenever
we do use without units it's always mean
second all right
well hopefully we will be getting units
and that this is
so freakin obscure I mean without
wrapping in an association and saying
what these things are I mean maybe I
would get used to this but by the time
what is this thing by the time we've got
three null lists this music is what's
that I'm sorry it means it has no memory
because those are the first three
arguments just the input is directly fed
into the output okay okay so what is
this that the thing is connected to my
computer on dev TTY bla bla bla is that
the idea yes that's that so it's the
cord is getting downloaded and this is
some random option this max value 100 is
a random option associated with port 11
which by the way notice here is not a
string for some reason those are strings
but those aren't so port 11 has that
extra option associated with it is that
correct yeah we want to say that because
these are these these registers maximum
value of the register is 256 we want to
say that our hundred should should be
that that's the maximum value that that
register before Deathly 11 mean 11 is
pin pin 11 on the same as zero whatever
I'm sorry I'm not done okay so that
could be a zero without a string right
yes yeah okay fine okay so these things
are going through an A to D into
something that is even though it says
analog it's really 256 yes
microcontrollers have built in a two and
A to D and D to a converters right but
they're not super high resolution as you
can understand they're 256 right 8-bit
right okay
okay so what the heck is that
yeah so now we are getting into the
device framework what is from ASCII
because it comes as character codes and
we want to get it back into what comes
as character codes what's coming over
the serial port I mean in a device frame
so after the believably low-level or
whatever okay so yeah so after that
device open that is the device framework
I see it but in bed code that actually
loaded the microcontroller embed so here
so here you see some use what this
device framework is going to do is pull
data back in no I get it I get it the
the microcontroller is running that code
and then the device framework is poking
the thing rightly is the connector after
the microcontroller is often running its
code that's right yeah okay so one of
the things that's an issue here is this
embed code has a destination which is
that that EV TTY right just the
microcontroller connected on that I
understand I understand
I got it right the part that okay the
thing I'm trying to understand is embed
code the function embed code the
ordinary function embed code doesn't
have a target like that so far as I
remember
did you know what I'm talking about I'm
sorry for web browsers right no embed
code is for you know JavaScript bro
it hasn't looked it does all right okay
I'm wrong okay terrific
okay all good okay that's great okay so
that is saying send this microcontroller
code how does that send it to that
location
fine it's a little weird that what comes
back I think this really is that a
representation of the device or is that
a representation of the code do you
understand my question
it's it holds several things
it holds information about the device
where the code was embedded it also has
information about the source code if I
disconnect the device from the wire from
from that you know port of my computer
mm-hmm the device but and then I reuse
this thing if the status is how I'm
gonna change the green status is gonna
change away from green okay but there's
nothing here that says this is connected
to dev TTY whatever in that
microcontroller code date it doesn't say
that so this is the fundamental this is
a fundamental difference between a
microcontroller embed code and the
device framework so microcontroller
embed code does not maintain a
connection after it has downloaded the
code whereas the device framework does
microcontroller embed code just embeds
the code and that's it right I mean one
of the things that sort of okay fair
enough
so it's sending the embedded code to
that destination where the
microcontroller receives it and the
microcontroller I don't know what you
know boot loaders look like and things
for microcontrollers but but if you just
say here's a bunch of bytes and you send
that to that port the microcontroller
just eats them in and says great that's
gonna be my code or what yeah so the
microcontroller gets this and it is so
in this case it's configured it
configures its inputs and outputs as
such as analog serial and whatnot and
then anybody can now talk to it and we
have chosen the device framework to talk
with no no no no you're not
understanding my point well when it says
when you say microcontroller embed code
right yeah what it does or three things
okay
it converts the expression to C code yep
the C code gets compiled with a tool
chain provided by the device maker yep
they all provide their own to
chains yep okay because it's sort of
it's not really quite see okay that is
ten it's gonna be loaded and they're
called programmers for it's just what
they're called it's real to me too
and that that does exactly what suma
said it configures it downloads it right
but if I if I run this again okay with a
different configuration that will simply
blow away whatever was in that
microcontroller before is that correct
yes so at any given time only one
program is loaded into each
microcontroller is that correct yes
why is no operating system no I
understand that but it might be loaded
in different places in memory and there
might be like the computer I first used
it when two always went to location
eight one eight one in memory to start
but presumably these microcontrollers
have some convention like that yes they
do
yeah so the whole flash memory is the
program is the whole thing is rewritten
and the pointer goes to the to the
preset place and starts reading again
okay fine but there's only one program
per microcontroller yes okay great okay
so this will always blow away what was
there before okay and all what you're
looking now this is all the device
framework now I can see that right no
data so what do you do here to task
remove so how did you get back what is
this doing this isn't this is just
giving me static data where is the
where's the thing that actually runs
that the thing in the microcontroller so
add a few inputs earlier that's where we
embedded the code to the microcontroller
and and using the device framework we
got the data where did you get the data
that's here yeah
so I'm appending to rpm so each time I
get the RPM value I'm storing it okay so
RPM l is that okay then what is this
motor data so some motor data is the
duty cycle RPM left and RPM right
but why aren't you showing that derive
from anything you're just typing this in
here because I yeah I'm getting yeah so
it's something duty cycle rpm and wolves
but but I'm getting it once alright no
no I understand that but but in this
example that you are showing here you
obviously got a value for duty cycle
it's zero in this case right
show me where it actually is reading so
in this particular thing you're saying
session submit scheduled tasks and that
scheduled tasks as by the way why is it
in this funky font well nevermind that
but the scheduled task is running how
often is running every sampling period
okay and the sampling period is SP which
was set to one or something whatever it
was okay fine great okay so that has
succeeded so if I look at rpm l after
that I will have never sent of device
read and that's what I am writing there
and motor data but why are you just
putting it in like copy paste you don't
want to do that you want to show people
how it runs just show how it runs I mean
because this one it's actually connected
to the hardware I understand but so it's
a frozen case you're not gonna be able
to show it in real time that's that I
understand that but just typing it in
it's not useful do you see what I'm
saying nobody knows what this is at this
point right so what you're showing you
think what we should do so you can at
least continue on show because show I
agree with Steve a we should show how
it's derived from those things that are
accumulated up there but then we can
still have and we should use icon eyes
and other things do not you know okay
okay
so we could say sort of here's a frozen
we could say you know yeah no but that's
what I do I say that see no no but what
I want to know is how did you get those
numbers right where did those numbers
come from
yeah okay so yeah those numbers I got
from device review you've got those
numbers from device read you got those
numbers in that lot the way we write
documentation we should show how we get
it right that's not saying how you got
it those numbers are the list rpm commas
something come as something is that not
correct yeah okay so that's what you
have to show what you have to show is
that the result here if the append to
RPM whatever this motor data is probably
a transpose of list rpm and something
else something else is that correct yeah
and each time the RPM is running I'm
also using a water meter and and reading
the voltage across the motor leads okay
where's that being done that I'm doing
physically with the physical setup see
I'm just below those gauges I explained
that in that one sentence so Wow
so there's something that isn't computer
achieved here there's something that's
achieved by you connecting something
with a volt meter exactly yeah I don't
think it's a great example I mean you
know can't you get something that reads
I mean I understand why that voltage
isn't read by the microcontroller the
microcontroller has an analog port just
connect that to the you know across
those that those leads and the
microcontroller should be able to read
it
am I making sense just like you can read
the you know device read buffer now now
here when you're doing a device read
buffer that's extremely ugly and you
know if if we're really going to be
using microcontrollers like this
shouldn't we provide code in the
microcontroller embed code that sends
stuff back in a form that isn't raw
bytes with terminators saying yes so
that is part of the device framework and
we have a prototype function for that
that will actually make all that code
getting device read buffer and device
right it'll make it more high level and
more sussing mean that's a question of
the embed code could be sending stuff in
the form
that the device framework will just read
it is that right or is that something
different it is yes so yeah you know
just we can specify high-level get list
but Stephen coming back to a question be
you see doing it using some fourth or
something it's more complicated than
this because if you are reading very
high voltages and the microcontroller
cannot read that see I'm getting six
volts and so on microcontroller will max
out at 5 volts then put a resistor there
or something I'll use a different motor
I mean I don't know but put you know put
a resistor but split the voltage I mean
the idea that you're by hand reading a
voltage here sort of spoils the point of
this okay but for a first project that I
don't really want to complicate the
model that we use fine so once you
explain what's going on and you arrived
I'll be ok no Stephen so this big thing
the reason I'm doing it like this year
is because this is not the main thrust
of the project the project this is this
is a big project and what we're doing
here is just getting the model of the
motor and that's not the end goal of
this project once we get the model we
want to control the speed when we are
controlling the speed that we do
everything automated from it so this is
getting the model yes he even here when
we are getting the model we are getting
data and fitting it and so on but then
the final end goal is to control the
speed where we don't do these so they
use Excel you could be isn't project
couldn't you here you really want normal
enough at one should just use predict we
need actual parameters otherwise you
don't get a model we need a natural
model that we can use oh I see what you
say you can't use a neural nut cuz you
have to download it to the
microcontroller
well that's but with the Olson needs to
fit in the systems framework
it needs to be there and needs to be
compiled able to the microcontroller
it's you know somebody on our live
stream suggest not using a pen too and I
agree with them as soon as we have the
capability to have
our new gosh I've forgotten what we're
calling them now a new expression object
like things you should be able to use
those instead
I'm sure um okay wow this is
unbelievably super complicated because
this is what engineers do yeah this this
is a project because in the in the
microcontroller microcontroller embed
code then the scope we have simple
examples but this is like a full-fledged
project I mean this is big you didn't
really start from the simplest I mean if
this was being taught in some college
class how long would students take to do
this project is that one lab project or
is this like a bigger thing depends on
your previous training but I've
certainly done things like this in one
lab okay well I'm trying to get my home
HVAC system working so I intend to use
something like this although I was
planning to have a computer in the loop
yeah I mean one reason to do you want to
use microcontrollers is that they are
dirt cheap
yeah I understand and they can be put in
all kinds of places and they probably
have low power exactly Wow
well that's cool I mean okay so let's
just review then oh god I mean this
stuff is so frigging low-level yeah
that's why we needed that that function
what's the function what function is it
going to be it's yeah it's called device
submit and then you're going yeah we can
specify high level that we want it as a
list or as these raw values ins and so
on I don't think device submit is the
right name device submit is an
asynchronous type thing yeah do you want
to like look at it now I can sure
but but this much love I don't
understand why it would be there I would
have thought it would be in the
microcontroller embed code function
which now that's a fine you know no no
okay
but so the microcontroller embed code
expects data in a certain format on a
serial port it expects various kinds of
bytes and so on is that right yeah just
a minute Litton okay I just put it in
the chat okay oh gosh so I managed to
hit the wrong thing here okay so so this
is something I Igor and I came up with
echo and submits an asynchronous task
okay they're just like sessions I mean
yeah right
okay that's what it should with a name
like that why is it all caps for read
yeah we can change it so we just saying
read and write
they're like keywords okay so what this
is doing
I don't understand this at all I mean
what this should instead be Wow I I
think this is kind of crazy
okay so device read normally has a let's
look at what device read normally does
if I can get any of these things to work
the new version is not working there
let's look at what device read does so I
see device read reads a parameter there
so that parameter can be real integer so
why can device read not just have a
thing that says read a list to
understand I'm asking yes why why can't
we make device read of list a real list
for example work yep yeah we can make
that work that would be a step up then
we also device writing well sure so that
whole block that you see where you say
it's like too low-level that that's the
whole thing we're trying tonight I know
I know that's what it's doing I'm just
saying I don't think this is the right
design you don't need to do I mean
there's a completely separate issue
which is whether it's asynchronous or
not but what I'm saying is if you're
doing it synchronously the right way to
do it is to just say device read comma
real list here or something or whatever
we call that type you get what I'm
saying yeah okay right you don't need
this this is a this is an orthogonal
this to this whole question about a
synchronicity is completely orthogonal
to this am I making sense okay so Roger
online am I missing something here
no I think I think that there will be
still go back and look I I'm not sure if
you you capture a lot of things I'm not
sure you capture everything right right
so device submit seems to have some
other kinds of things that it's doing
here this is read data
I am I'm just completely confused here
because these are seem to be examples
not a specification this is saying read
the data and then when you've read the
data well I don't understand what this
means read the rule values and assign it
to you does that mean assign each raw
value to that as it comes in or what yes
that's what that means
it's assigning and then if you want to
up and I can see that yeah I can see
that but I mean I'm saying okay
so list what does that do because if
you're assigning every raw value then
what does it mean when you say list
there yes yeah when you look at raw
values it involves like the delimiter
bite the start byte and so on this will
this will put into a more sanitized just
as a list yeah I understand but you just
told me that every single number it
reads it sets you to that number here
correct yeah whereas here you're asking
for a list and so what I'm asking is I'm
assuming that that list is accumulating
the successive values of you is that
correct only if you do up into what does
it do in this case because it's an
individual value here that you're saying
set an individual value what does the
word list mean that it will just create
a list of that individual value so that
list
yeah will make sense they make sense of
you're reading multiple very tall system
yeah right in this case here it makes
sense right if there are multiple u sub
i's being read yeah oh yeah that's why
you're right yeah for the multiple you
service the list will make sense in this
case low values sounds like it's
multiple values so I don't go and
understand that does that mean that that
across different things that are coming
across the wire from the microcontroller
for example one of them might be
temperature one of them might be
humidity one of them might be light
level that those three things will each
successively have be set you will
successively be
set to those three if you say rule
values whereas enlist what you'll get is
a list that contains temperature
humidity like that was that right yeah
in yes it'll be a raw values let's ask
your question again please okay listen
this time okay no I'm saying if you've
got let's say just two things
temperature and humidity right those are
coming across the wire from the
microcontroller yeah right okay what I
understand that first thing to do is
first it sets you to temperature then it
sets you to humidity is that correct no
the the raw values it will just set the
till that delimiter byte whatever is
coming will be said to you Roger help me
out here yeah so there's the parsing
that was going on there do you
understand what I was saying I don't
think it ever does that Stephen I don't
think it's it sort of crosses in that
case what's the difference between list
and row values I think that you get rid
of all those delimited bytes the main
thing is in enlist you don't have to do
from character e because list lists what
list does - Robin uses just from row
values a completely different thing okay
all right fine so the raw values are the
actual bytes so it's an A to D that has
256 values for the for the you know that
decodes into to 256 values stored in a
byte and that byte might be the letter
you know the the character ampersand or
something exactly represent okay but
that is completely crazy you should be
using byte arrays for this you should in
no way be using characters am I making
sense okay yeah there's nothing to do
with characters right now maybe you
started developing this before you know
ages ago before we have byte arrays but
byte arrays or what you should be using
for this okay angry
okay now at least I understand what this
is doing okay now what I'm gonna say is
I don't think this is the right way to
do this because I think this business
here for the submit functions we have
handler functions that do things
typically yeah okay so but but I think
I'm understanding the flow here so the
flow is you define in microcontroller
embed code you are defining here the
this is the device type this is the
configuration of its input ports its
output ports yes and you have various
kinds of essentially macro things you
can do there like for example you can
say max value of whatever which is a way
of essentially adding a piece of code
that you're not explicitly putting into
the controller but it is a convenience
for for example stopping your
microcontroller blowing up or whatever
else it is am i is that correct yes yeah
okay so so the additional items here so
at the raw level the microcontroller has
certain most pins certain things are
connected to those pins it might be an A
to D it might be something else right
yeah okay and the the the the signature
of what's on the pins of a particular
microcontroller is stored where it's not
stored anyway the code is written for to
configure them my credential medicine no
no but but wait a second isn't it the
case that the hardware of the my
controller it has a pin pin number seven
yeah
what does pin number seven do it has an
A to D on the other side of it if I'm or
is that not the case so can you
configure a pin to be either analog or
digital we can yes so the agenda the
GPIO pins they can take they can be they
can configure that sometimes for SPI
sometimes for analog sign the same pin I
get it I get it okay so we have so there
is a signature of the the
microcontroller with its configuration
which includes pin 7 is
a digital input blah blah blah yeah okay
now in this controller thing here
wherever it is if I wanted to so the
controller is mapping inputs to outputs
in some way so let's say that I wants to
take two inputs and I just want to make
an adding machine I want to take two
inputs which are specified as bytes and
I want to produce an output which is the
sum of those bytes okay right how would
I do that
what's the minimal controller that does
that it's a transfer function model 1 1
so when I represent this controller the
only way I can do it is through this
essentially matrix technology of
transfer functions is that correct yes
oh I also allowed to just write
Mathematica expression but that's it
like you can write u 1 u 2 u 1 plus u 2
well so for what operations can you do
that for things which don't have memory
actually and if you look at
microcontroller embed code in
generalization the next extension I show
that it's very limited set of operation
Stephen you know so there are no
registers in these things yeah so if we
do it like this then we cannot have any
memory we just take two inputs the first
output is the sum of the two inputs the
second eleazar it just my confusion here
but don't microcontrollers I mean they
can have memory right yes they do but if
you specify it as an expression we don't
have we don't have a mechanism to give
memory except in those system models as
of now but I mean I see but I mean we
could in principle imagine a module
where the variable X is something which
is stored in the register and the
microcontroller and so on right yes so
this is it's something you have to do in
the Wolfram language something beyond
the system models where we say that this
is system models but when you say system
model you're talking about one of these
state-space models for example whereas
in system model when we talk about
system model
blah blah blah that is not something
which can necessarily be reduced to one
of these states base models is that true
no no no they can't not in general
however you can first of all they're
often very big at once when your model
with high fidelity sure that they're way
down they won't fit in a typical
microcontroller no not even close on the
other hand what you often are interested
in why you build these big models is for
everything around it not only let's say
in this case the motor the motor is one
component in a big system yes and and
you want to see how that you know fits
into that big system that's why they're
complicated and we can derive linearized
models for instance for a subset of
those system models which you can then
represent in this state space model
formal right and then you can design
controller signal processing algorithms
based on that which we have works so in
modern times if I'm understanding you
know people are trying to build sort of
generalized microcontrollers that have
known that's inside them is that true
yes a little bit bigger machines than
8-bit I think there are people who are
trying to do 8-bit no that's but that's
different story probably yeah but but
all of those you know most of them come
with you know what what you do today if
you're gonna run neural nets is that
they often have a functional block and
you have to be able to convert your
neural net model into a language that's
understand by that block so and I think
that that's very interesting for our
neural nets to understand what but under
standard formats it can actually go into
these embedded neural nets that are
coming up left and right in other places
so I think that that's on us to sort of
kind of fit into that well I think the
MX net is going to be able to target a
bunch of those things I'm guessing to
but it would be nice for us to check out
what we're how far that's come right
okay so look in terms of the details of
this design my tendency is you know this
thing where we have deeply nested
lists I have to say I think we should be
using rules and maybe some associations
in these things rather than in fact you
know the rules get rid of one level a
list but you still need a list about
foot stair or input so that's fine
that's not so the other question is
whether we should be using the typed
wrapper of the compiler for these things
is that crazy no it's not crazy in fact
that's one of the things to come up
later if you look here in the review
okay
well oh I could tunnel type signature
yeah so this was done prior to the
compiler existing right
okay but yeah I mean so using the type
trapper I mean these are very simple
types Steven it's not they're not
parametrized types it's nothing I know
but but that's okay I mean it's just
like we have types like integer and so
all right there at that level right the
that's very level right now well you're
looking at the serial serial what does
that mean go ahead it means two outputs
both are serial because since there are
two the system has two oh I see I see I
see okay when you say serial that like
analog means it's just going to be a
certain level yes serial means that it's
what it's got an initiation by to
termination bite and so on or what yeah
yes so where do you configure I mean
like the serial thing could have all
kinds of random junk like parity and all
kinds of stuff yeah how do you specify
that so there are default values and
then if you look at that data object
that has returned and asks for the
serial property it will tell you what
values it used and and if you want we
can give an option there that's in yeah
we can we can we can individually
specify the parity the stock by the
start byte and so on okay since the
details of that argument serial log
maybe I get it I get it
okay okay I'm understanding
boy this is really low level I mean much
lower level than I even is Steven I mean
okay it's okay I mean these things you
know so what would you do if you didn't
use a microcontroller to get at a
similar price point you might try to
build an FPGA or something yeah but it's
cheaper if you can use you know
off-the-shelf how much the
microcontrollers cost taking me 50 cents
yeah and so on your drone you know the
motor controllers on that drone there
are microcontrollers yeah how many
microcontrollers are there in a typical
car or something in the order of 50 or
so okay and each of those things so so
for us the only thing we're representing
is you know these system model states
based models right I'm sure that most
microcontrollers somebody wrote custom C
code and just yeah that's how they go
okay so if you go to one of these sites
the people that sell either
microcontrollers or micro boards how do
they specify projects most about that
projects is how to write the C code I
say okay
but we've trivialized that step at least
in the case where it can be represented
with the state space model that's
correct okay you characterize what can
be represented by the state space model
it's I mean so I mean our state space
model a little funky because they they
are so everything sort of that the most
things that you want to do with control
and signal processing is that first of
all so that's a big class of things
yes States makes models can be very
advanced they don't have to be linear
you know and and at general the non
linear state-space model is not linear
as you probably guessed from its name
yes right so fundamentally what's
happening is it's like a big function
without with with some amount of memory
right and what's happening is you know
inputs coming in and basically I mean
it's
it's very similar in concept to a modern
nomads inputs are coming in you know
maybe it's a recurrent Network and it's
remembering some stuff maybe it's not
maybe it's just you know goes straight
through and then fundamentally stuff is
coming out that is you know the outputs
and microcontroller but this is a kind
of a I mean I know yeah I mean the idea
for you know I mean that idea for neuron
that comes from here so it's yes yes I
know in the history was was right people
were doing neural nets before they were
even doing well they're about the same
time that early so in fact I'm just
about to go to something where it's
supposed to be a a rerun of the Macy
conferences on cybernetics from 1946 to
1953 I just I thought on my desk here
the the Proceedings of all those
conferences which I haven't opened yet
yes so so the thing that took off first
from cybernetics lost control and
Norbert Wiener who wrote cybernetics the
book at least yes and yes yeah he worked
at the radar lab in Boston right indeed
right rad lab and and the thing that he
came up with was a he was very proud of
was a bomb site right of how to do that
they ended up not using his but the
ideas that he came up with was later
refined to become usable is called a
wiener filter right okay that's the but
that's how he got sort of the insights
it's like oh my god this is a curse
everywhere he wrote the book you know I
just opened this proceedings at a random
page and the topic that the running head
at the top of the page is communication
between sane and insane
well I mean but they were discovering
this thing that the human body regulates
pH level in blood and that's like a
controller
yes it's covered it's like it seems to
occur everywhere right so right well in
case the fair enough so okay so the
point of what we're doing here is to
automate so so how but the point I
wanted to say too was control was the
thing that took off
and became very industrial and practical
and very advanced and you have it all
around you you know when people can
program this stuff usually then are they
doing it from symbolic state-space
models or are they doing it you know
line by line in C code line by line in C
code it's a mix of both yeah there are
some most experts do it line by line and
C code and so the C code we generate is
it decently optimal or optimal enough at
least it's I mean it's I think it's
optimal and I mean it's it's done during
the time that the microcontroller has to
react it's probably right exactly so
it's hard real time you know the physics
doesn't wait for you unfortunately so so
what is the minimal so you have a
variety of microcontrollers that you're
supporting here does it matter which one
you use I mean do they all have
different characteristics or are they is
it like general-purpose CPUs mostly yeah
they have different memory so if if the
controller and the features are more
involved we cannot use a small amount we
need other than the memory parameter is
it the case that it's just up to us to
compile it for the correct instruction
set and so on or is it that different
microcontrollers have different I mean
you know if it was general-purpose
computers doesn't matter if you're using
a BeagleBone or a raspberry positive
different amounts of numbers of analog
ATD converters functions different other
factors too some of them consume more
power than the others so yeah I get it
but I mean fundamentally what we okay
just different instruction sets so okay
so you connect the thing to your
computer it pushes the code into flash
memory then you disconnect it and you
know as soon as you put it on a battery
it will start you know doing it's
running its program is that correct yes
and if you want to monitor it that's for
debugging purposes that's when the
device framework comes in so we can you
know understand that's the way that we
can peek and poke at this
microcontroller yes I get it
well this is nice but I mean I think the
only thing I would have to say is I
think we should clean up the device you
know the way the device framework
interacts with this we should I mean you
know what you're telling me is for most
of these microcontroller operations in
the end it shines to buy em in so much
trouble I was like okay I am horrible
okay nice okay I should go too but but
all right well nice stuff nice stuff I
think we're gonna need to look at this
yet again preferably and not too long so
that we haven't completely forgotten
what's going on here but there's there's
a bit of syntactic cleanup but otherwise
you know cool okay so I so I'll wait for
the next meeting before I go with any
design change at this point right that
is correct yes yeah okay sounds good
good work okay yeah thank you bye bye